bill maher is getting a lot of credit
right now
because he's coming out and defending
gina carano my colleague i never thought
that i would have a colleague
in political media who was an mma
fighter and a disney movie star
but hey you know this is a pretty weird
time that we're living in and gina
carano
was fired from disney just for being a
conservative right and they they used
as an excuse some social media posts
she'd made but the social media posts
were completely
innocuous they were inoffensive they
didn't they didn't really say anything
wrong at all
and so bill maher who is a man of the
left
is defending her and saying she
shouldn't be canceled and bill maher is
doing this this is
very much in his wheelhouse because
even though he's a left winger he's
always sort of opposed political
correctness or at least he thinks he
does
he had he hosted a show called
politically incorrect
he's he's uh not not of the hard left
but he's not a conservative either and
he's making an
argument that while i appreciate it and
i'm glad he's standing up
for a conservative here against the
left-wing mob i don't think the argument
is particularly effective
so bill maher is defending gina carano
on the grounds that she did not deserve
to be canceled
take a listen the mandalorians gina
carano is a person i'd never heard of
and resent that i have now
she's some conservative wrestling chick
who kicks ass on a show i wouldn't watch
if i was in prison
and she made some nazi analogy who
doesn't these days
you're like the nazis is the new i don't
like you
it's always okay with trump's a nazi
that disqualifies her for marching
around
planet who gives a [ __ ] in a helmet
by the way you can't work in hollywood
if you don't believe what we
believe yeah in the 50s that's exactly
what the left
complained they were being told so this
is a funny bit
i laughed a couple times while while
watching it the first time and i'm
really i
really do appreciate that bill would
stand up for a conservative who's being
canceled by the left-wing mob
but it's that argument there at the end
that that means i can't totally go along
with him
he says you know in the 50s this is what
leftists complained about and what he's
referring to is anti-communism
and the anti-communism of the 1950s is
something that has been
totally rewritten by left-wing
historians
who are still trying to cover up the
fact that they were defending the
communists in in the
30s 40s and 50s this is sometimes called
mccarthyism
and mccarthyism is sometimes conflated
with blacklisting in hollywood
senator joe mccarthy had absolutely
nothing to do with hollywood
blacklisting
no person of any political persuasion
whether they love mccarthy or hate
mccarthy
who has actually looked at the facts can
say mccarthy had something to do with
the black listing in hollywood
mccarthy had nothing to do with huwak
better known
or i suppose it's better known as huwak
now but it ought to be known as the
house committee on
un-american activities what happened in
the 1950s
and really more in the 30s and 40s is
that the soviet
government our enemies in the cold war
had spies placed
throughout the federal government had
very high level spies in the federal
government this is not a conspiracy
theory
we know this we ended up rooting out a
couple hundred of them
at least the most notable one is alger
hiss who was a high level state
department official he had been at the
doj
he helped found the united nations he
was directly working for the soviet
union
he was a spine in the united states if
you want to read a good book about it
you can read witness
by whitaker chambers at the time this
was a hotly debated political issue
because
the republicans were the the ones who
were hardcore anti-communists here
and the communist problem festered
during democratic administrations in
fact the reason dwight eisenhower got
elected
was because of the the backlash
against democrats going soft on
communism
john f kennedy defended joe mccarthy
bobby kennedy
went to joe mccarthy's funeral it was
absolutely right and just for the united
states to root out communists
in the 1930s 40s and 50s it was a matter
of
great national importance was that
cancel culture sort of
you know it this is so crazy to me for
the conservatives who
just sort of maybe reflexively because
they believe whatever they were taught
in public school
the ones who decry mccarthyism who buy
the left's line on mccarthyism
conservatives out of one side of their
mouth will decry
the cultural marxism of hollywood and
the universities
and say that we've got to take back the
institutions and we can't let these
leftists destroy our culture through
hollywood and through
the universities and then at the same
time
they'll decry mccarthyism and cancel
culture and say that
we can never root out anybody we just
need to debate them in the free
marketplace of ideas
when you say that we need to take back
the institutions take back hollywood
take back the universities
what you are saying is we need to get
the leftists
out of those places we need to
censor them in a certain sense we need
to kick them out of their positions of
influence
on the basis of their ideological views
you are defending a sort of mccarthyism
but then on the other hand you say but
we would never do that sort of thing the
leftists are the new mccarthyists in
reality what happens is
people defend their standards and no
society is perfectly open
and nobody believes that if a guy walks
up to his water cooler at the office
with an armband
the swastika screams sig heil that he
has any right to keep his job
and and the debate that's really
happening right now is over which set of
standards we're going to have
the good set of standards that defends
america and defends
our faith and defends our traditions and
our way of life
or the bad set of standards which says
america's evil and americans should be
divided and hate one another and
degenerate throuples should be able to
create designer babies without any care
for the child himself
or herself which set of standards are
you going to defend
because if we have the good traditional
moral version then you can't have the
throuple version
you actually have to exclude that you
have to say no you have to cancel that
and it would be a very good thing to
cancel that if you enjoyed that break
from disinformation historical revision
and screaming about the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button
so that you never miss another video
[Music]
you